let's talk about madagascar and why
people there are starving
[Applause]
in parts of the country they're eating
locusts leaves clay or even bits of shoe
leather just to survive
and what's going on in madagascar is
also something new madagascar right now
is the only place in the world to be
affected
by famine-like conditions
because of climate change southern
madagascar has barely had any rain in
the last five years rivers have dried up
there's not enough water to drink let
alone to grow food
so why is climate change affecting
madagascar so badly why are so many
people going hungry
and is this kind of thing about to get
much more common
madagascar is a big island off the east
coast of africa and is one of the
poorest countries in the world
on average people there earn just over a
dollar a day and right now there's a
drought in the south the worst in 40
years
just look at this satellite image it
uses infrared technology to show whether
vegetation is healthy basically the
darker the brown the worse it is and
there's a lot of dark brown almost
everyone there relies on growing their
own food so this drought is devastating
you meet families mothers especially who
have very very small children some are
have up to four five six children
tiny children skeleton children bones
and and you know very little flesh
children with very protruding bellies
who you know almost comatose because
they don't have energy more than a
million people in southern madagascar
are what the un calls food insecure that
means they can't get enough nutritious
food to eat and out of those around 14
000 are in what's called phase 5 the
catastrophe stage that's when people
start dying of starvation or
malnutrition and disease and that number
is expected to double by october because
no one's sure the rain is going to come
and madagascar is heading into what's
known as lean season that's the period
between planting and harvesting and you
can imagine for a farmer this is super
critical because
this is the period now where it's almost
you know make or break live or die
october is soon and if we don't have a
rain again on november
like the next year will be
even um even worse so how did madagascar
end up here well there are lots of
reasons for decades the governments have
been pretty unstable and the country
ranks near the bottom in a lot of
important categories whether it's income
corruption or what the world bank calls
human capital basically whether a
country invests in things like education
and health that's the baseline
then you add covid19 the complications
that brings
and then there's climate change
[Music]
so we know that greenhouse gas emissions
are leading to more extreme weather that
was one of the big conclusions in a
recent report by the ipcc the world's
top climate scientists and when it comes
to madagascar there are really two
things going on one on land one at sea
let's start on land southern madagascar
is already pretty dry but the last six
years have been exceptionally warm when
the air is warmer the molecules move
further apart and the air can hold more
water vapor which means it can suck up
more moisture from the land
so if the land is already dry because of
a lack of rain
warmer air makes it all worse it's like
the atmosphere is thirstier
now what's happening in the sea is that
global warming is creating pockets of
water that are exceptionally warm
that changes the wind patterns and leads
to more rain in those areas
climate change made the eastern pacific
you know much much warmer in 2015-16
which produced a massive drought all
across southern africa and in southern
madagascar and that was the kind of
beginning of this drought
everyone knows that there's a change
like um
it's getting dry and drier it basically
is people living on the front line of
climate change
because they've had no rain no decent
water
that they are now
absolutely living
living in the most you know the most
minimum conditions they have nothing
this is what environmentalists mean when
they talk about climate justice
madagascar produces just 0.01
of all global carbon emissions but look
what's happening there are people who
have done nothing to contribute to
climate change and yet they're burying
the brunt of of something that's that
that's actually you know having a you
know colossal impact on on their lives
one of the things that wealthier nations
can do
is to work
uh you know with these insecure nations
proactively
to
develop ways to manage weather and
climate risk that issue is going to be
on the table at cop26 the major u.n
climate summit that's happening in
november we need to go to the roots of
the economic crisis and we need to treat
it as a crisis and unless the people in
power are willing to do that now in cop
then it will just continue like now uh
it's no longer a matter of
you know
debating whether uh action had to be
taken now in five years time or ten
years time it's a matter of taking
action at the moment right now i think
we all share this experience of like
holy moly this has gotten a lot worse
really fast unless you know we mitigate
and we do submissions
really quickly we're going to see more
of the same in the very near future
right now in madagascar humanitarian
groups are working hard to get food to
the people who need it most but the
bigger questions aren't going away
like how we make sure millions more
don't starve because of what we're doing
to the planet
if you're interested in the debate about
how to protect the environment check out
our recent start here episode on ecocide
and be sure to subscribe to al jazeera
so you don't miss our new episodes and
if there's a topic you think we should
be covering let us know in the comments
[Music]